we get to this third density this human
density now this is very
highly sought after obviously
because you become self-aware you become
aware
that you're aware you become aware
that you have choice that you have will
that when you're exposed to the choice
of do i serve myself or do i
serve other people which we'll talk
about as
sts service to self versus
sto service to others
you have will you have choice you have
polarity
right so self-awareness and polarity
this is typically what's also called the
third
density or 3d matrix
so when people talk about the matrix
they're
referencing something of course that's
also used in
mathematics but they're talking about it
in a sense of
the government in terms of the economic
machinery in terms of
politicians in terms of propaganda in
terms of all the main
media companies in terms of all of the
fast food and high fructose corn syrup
and all
of the endarkenment and asleepening
mechanisms that keep people
like algorithmic sheep
than liberated
sovereign gnostic
beings that know their true infinite
nature